Emanuel macón llegó a la casa blanca
para limar asperezas con Joe biden la
discusión bilateral se centró en la ley
de reducción de inflación estadounidense
que la Casa Blanca promovió para
fortalecer la economía y que fue tildada
de proteccionista por macón sin embargo
ahora los líderes coinciden en un
trabajo más coordinado como lo mostró
nuestra discusión el objetivo de los
Estados Unidos no es limitar el acceso a
sus industrias y hay proyectos ahora en
curso pero yo sé que esta no es la
intención del presidente pude hablarlo
ayer con distintos senadores y
representantes en el congreso
biden reforzó que la agenda de los
países aliados debe ser común y
beneficiosa para todos en temas
comerciales tecnológicos y de cambio
climático
mi punto es que estamos de vuelta los
negocios Europa también íbamos a
continuar creando trabajadores en
manufactura en Estados Unidos pero no a
expensas de Europa
otro tema protagonista de la conferencia
de prensa fue la guerra en Ucrania el
presidente ha propuesto un plan de paz
en diez puntos y creo que tenemos que
trabajar con él Porque existe una
voluntad real de parte de los ucranianos
de entrar al campo de las discusiones lo
reconocemos y lo felicitamos
bailen por su parte aseguró que no tiene
planes inmediatos de reunirse con Putin
pero
estoy preparada para hablar con el
presidente Putin
Sí realmente hay un interés de su parte
y si está buscando una manera de
terminar la guerra y él no ha hecho esto
aún el mensaje es claro Washington y
París seguirán actuando en conjunto en
defensa de Ucrania siguiendo la línea de
la otan organización en la que Estados
Unidos es el principal contribuyente y
Francia al tercero se espera que este
viernes Emmanuel macón concluya su
visita a Estados Unidos en Luisiana